bien que l'histoire est efficace jusqu'à
tiberi et sonnant comme quoi il ya
toujours du positif même dans le négatif
avait fini ça toute la journée moi comme
ça je suis pas d'issue en plus des
nouvelles commandes pourquoi s'en
prendre à ses syndicats votre
appartement qui s'est fait cambrioler
j'ai pensé à ma fille ya toujours du
noir mais la vie est tellement amoureuse
ou comment je me demande s'il n'est pas
allé chercher vos culottes
alors là ça serait donc est ce qu'on
vous a pris à part des culottes
on m'a pris un vase ok je te dis
beaucoup parce qu'il venait de maman et
puis c'est j'ai toujours les toujours vu
bon mais comme j'aime sa ville devant
toute la détresse qui a tous les
malheurs qui seul en temps en temps
parler en ce moment ouais je me dis
finalement cava sais rien et je me dis
que recevoir mu est résigné positive
dans l'oeil et voilà et faut-il il faut
tout relativiser les questions des gens
merveilleux
est ce que c'est vrai alors pour parler
encore des magazines j'ai lu que vous
aviez dit que sophie thalmann
elles feraient bien de cacher son
oreille parce que les oreilles au chaud
oui je trouve que c'est le seul défaut
quel à sophie et que c'est vrai que
j'aime mieux quand elle a les cheveux
stallman les rails un peu en dessous
linda c'est quoi son défaut aïda est
parfaite
maintenant si c'est vrai
comment on pourrait dire le défaut de
chacun non non mon cher vous avez
beaucoup de charme et c'est vous auriez
fait une jolie miss où j'étais petit
fallait pour voir si le cognac
écoutez pour l'instant ça m'est
difficile de lui voir des défauts enfin
partout où elle va tout le monde la
trouve ravissante est sous le charme
c'est vrai que j'ai énormément de charme